[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 c'est l'essentiel de l'actualité
locale nous sommes le jeudi 19 novembre
voici les titres la crise sanitaire
pousse les consommateurs à acheter en
ligne
résultat la poste constate une hausse de
30% du volume des colis en ile de france
depuis la fin du premier confinement
pour affronter le rush des fêtes et des
promotions de fin novembre le groupe
recrute actuellement reportage à lagence
colis de poissy la décision finale est
encore attendu les restaurants ne
pourrait rouvrir que le 15 janvier
prochain voire même plus tard en
attendant la vente en reporter reste
possible mais le bilan est très mitigé
pour les professionnels et d'autres
arrivent en revanche à tirer leur
épingle du jeu
c'est le cas notamment des food trucks
et permettre aux personnes en situation
de handicap de découvrir un métier en
duo avec un salarié c'est le principe du
duo day qui se déroulait aujourd'hui à
la mairie de mantes la jolie s'est
associé à cette opération en accueillant
six stagiaires le temps d'une journée
assure également tout à l'heure le
témoignage d'une yvelinoise elle nous
racontera comment elle vit sa grossesse
en cette période si particulière celle
de la crise sanitaire
[Musique]
alors que certains secteurs sont à
l'arrêt avec le nouveau confinement
d'autres mettent en ce moment au
contraire les bouchées doubles est la
livraison de colis notamment connaît une
forte hausse depuis trois semaines qui
devrait s'intensifier encore avec en
ligne de mire est les fêtes de fin
d'année le groupe la poste tente donc de
trouver des solutions pour s'adapter
reportage au site de poissy avec astrid
bergère et célia gars de son go il est 6
heures du matin et une cinquantaine
d'agents colis charge déjà leur camion
pour commencer les livraisons entre 7h15
et 7h30 dans tout le périmètre nord des
yvelines soit 57 communes depuis le
confinement
ce sont environ 35 miccoli jour qui sont
traités ce qui est beaucoup plus que je
prendrais devrait traiter normalement
avec la période de confinement c'est
environ + 28 % par rapport à ce qu'on
avait prévu initialement
novembre et décembre sont des périodes
déjà très chargé entre le black friday
et noël mais cette année avec le
confinement et les magasins fermés
les commandes sur internet explosent
pour répondre à la demande
trente personnes vont être embauchées
c'est également un nombre de circuits
supplémentaires on passe de 150 circuit
à 214 circuit sur le site et on
multiplie les vagues de préparation
comme celle qui est en train de se
dérouler actuellement un circuit
représente un quartier dans une commune
ou un opérateur de livraison va livrer
les colis durant une journée
mirella est opératrice colis depuis
quatre ans aujourd'hui elle va à base
mon depuis avril 2019 le site de poissy
est automatisée une nouvelle machine qui
trient les colis par circuits et permet
de gagner du temps avec cette machine à
moëze 2009 en tirent pas trop de
chariots
parce que l'ancienne machine c'était un
tapis roulant donc il fallait plus de
portes de colis plus de déplacements
plus pour le chargement tandis qu'ici on
est directement à l'arrière du camion
donc on peut directement fine et les
coller dans le camion et partir en
tournée
le site colissimo de poissy est ouvert
du lundi au samedi soir 24 heures sur 24
pour permettre de préparer et trier les
colosses et pour faire face à l'afflux
de colis en cette fin d'année la poste
recrute plus de 100 personnes dans les
yvelines comment postuler quels sont les
postes proposés
regardez cette interview menée par
astrid bergère célia gars de son go pour
les moyens techniques
bonjour laurent ménagez vous êtes
directeur opérationnel colissimo en ile
de france
bonjour alors c'est une période très
chargée en ce moment à la poste vous
avez lancé une vaste campagne de
recrutement
combien de postes sont disponibles et
effectivement c'est une très grosse
période pour nous sur cette cette femme
allait renforcer aussi par les aspects
de confinement est donc la poste est
organisée avec plus de 9000 emplois en
renfort sur cette activité depuis deux
périodes colis c9000 en dans la france
entière en ile-de-france et dans les
yvelines ça représente combien de cas
alors c'est effectivement 9000 au niveau
national sur l'île de france et plus de
800 recrutements qui sont opérés sur
cette partie colis plus spécifiquement
encore dans nos établissements qu'au
lycée plus de
c'est plus de 350 à l'échelle du
département
on est à plus de 115 emplois jeunes en
se référant jusqu'à jusqu'à cette balade
de noël d'accord et s quels sont les
postes ciblés c'est pour ce pour faire
quoi
alors il ya plusieurs types de postes
lui que vous pouvez voir le plus
fréquemment ce avec le poste de deux
facteurs d'opérateurs de livraison on a
également des agents de traitement qui
sont plutôt sur la partie non plateforme
de tri et puis on a également des
chargés de clientèle en bureau qui vont
accueillir aussi les clients qui
viendront chercher des colis en bureau
de poste où qu ils viennent également
ont expédié et donc concrètement dès les
horaires c'est quoi ça c'est pour
qu'elle la journée type alors sur la
partie des oraisons ben voilà on a des
opérations qui sont assez matinale là
dessus donc ça peut être des orchidées
pas qui démarre à 5 ou 6 heures du matin
et sur lequel après en fonction des
vagues de livraison
tout au long de la tout au long de la
journée sur les bureaux de poste des
aspects les plus classiques
là-dessus ce en fonction de l'accueil de
la clientèle et sur nos opérations de
nos plateformes de tri pardon là on est
sur des agents 24-28 quasiment sept
jours sur sept dans cette période de fin
d'année qui peut postuler sur la partie
des des métiers de la livraison bien sûr
faut avoir le permis de conduire la tube
l'ensemble de la population peut
postuler sur les
les opérations de traitement tu sais les
qualifie finalement pas non plus des
qualifications particulières dont on
peut accueillir un public assez large et
comment donc justement fait pour
postuler à ces postes
alors il ya plusieurs canaux possibles
le sud d'avoir la poste dispose d'un
site internet spécifique qui s'appelle
la poste recrute et apprendre à des
partenaires on assure que son pôle
emploi ou encore les agences d'intérim
qui font les opérations aussi deux jours
signer ou qui nous délecte des du
personnel et donc c'est des postes pour
combien temps c'est des cdd c'est quel
type de poste alors c'est plutôt des cdd
on a également un petit peu de l'intérim
plutôt sur la partie des plateformes ont
délaissé l'idée qui nous emmène
généralement jusqu'à
la période de noël on a une deuxième en
fait
picard est forcément moins forte que la
première à partir de janvier que ce sont
les soldes et on est amer proposé aussi
notamment aux meilleurs éléments entre
eux de pouvoir continuer avec nous sur
sur cette deuxième période des soldes
est donc jusqu'à quand on peut postuler
la balle assez c'est bon là on est en
train heureusement de boucler ces
recrutements il peut encore avoir
quelques ajustements dans
l'établissement
oui mais voilà aujourd'hui dans nos
établissements sont organisés pour faire
face déjà à ce que deux colis qui est
déjà très présent et donc après ces
recrutements un précieux cdd de deux
trois mois qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire on
peut rester à la poste alors tout le
monde ne pourra pas rester puisque ça
c'est effectivement ces recrutements
correspondent aussi un pic d'activité un
surcroît d'activité
là-dessus qui à un moment donné voilà
sur lequel les volumes vont redescendre
en revanche pour nous c'est aussi une
pareille très favorable pour pouvoir
évaluer
voilà nos différents collaborateurs qui
nous rejoignent de manière temporaire et
un certain nombre d'entre eux voilà ont
l'occasion de pouvoir aussi continuer
sur la forme d'un d'un s'est dit là
dessus sinon bien sûr là la
disponibilité et l'envié de continuer
l'aventuré au sein du groupe la poste et
donc vous parler d'un pic d'activité
plus globalement comment ça se passe
avec le confinement alors nous on a eu
effectivement une année tout à fait
exceptionnel en termes de volume qui
s'est déclenché à la première période on
va dire au mois de mai du du confinement
sur le format des parties sur les
croissance extrêmement forte de l'ordre
de 30% sur lequel les français ont eu
aussi un usage beaucoup plus importants
du millionnaire donc ça nous a
effectivement occasionné des volumes
beaucoup plus important à
en livraison nous sommes organisés en
conséquence on est rentré dans cette
deuxième période
de confinement des fermetures de
commerces de proximité qui accentue
encore un petit peu plus cette partie là
et là sur les 2/3 de la semaine on est
plutôt sur deux +50 par rapport à
l'année dernière donc sur des volumes
extrêmement important on regardera le
comment se passera la prochaine échéance
sur la réouverture des commerces de
proximité
la tuile qui permettra aussi d'avoir
différentes canaux de distribution merci
beaucoup leur ménage et je vous remercie
dans l'actualité économique également la
région ile de france a dévoilé les
projets retenus dans le cadre de son
dispositif relance industrie au total 75
entreprises franciliennes vont
bénéficier d'une subvention est de plus
de 42 millions d'euros pour la
relocalisation l'implantation la
transformation ou la diversification et
d'activité industrielle regarder parmi
ces sociétés 16 sont yvelinoise ce sont
pour la plupart de petites et moyennes
entreprises ou de structures de taille
intermédiaire on retrouve différents
secteurs d'activité comme l'aéronautique
le spatial la défense la santé ou encore
l'alimentaire se sont parfois est des
projets pour augmenter les capacités de
production la productivité ramener des
outils industriels de l'étranger vers la
france ou encore diversifier les marchés
et des investissements qui vont
s'accompagner de créations d'emplois
l'une des priorités recherché par la
région ile de france au travers de son
plan de relance
depuis le début du confinement les
restaurants ont le droit de fonctionner
uniquement en vente à emporter une
aubaine pour certains un restaurateur
mais pour d'autres ce modèle n'est pas
avantageux exemple dans deux enseignes
de montigny le bretonneux avec célia
gars de 100 go et bixente mayence anti
steban débattent boot des pastilles à
des briques ou encore des pâtisseries
orientales dans ce restaurant à montigny
le bretonneux la vente à emporter est un
succès avec plus d'une vingtaine de
clients parmi 10 oui ça marche bien et
puis ça permet aussi de garder un
certain lien avec les clients qui
attendent en confinement ne voyais pas
trop de personnes et puis ça leur permet
d'avoir un commerce de proximité
selon les propriétaires la fréquentation
s'explique par l'emplacement de
l'établissement situé dans l'espace
saint quentin à montigny le bretonneux
on allait nicolas gagnent ou qu'ils sont
pas très bien placé
on arrive à capter un certain flux on a
des personnes qui habitent sur place et
on a aussi des personnes qui travaillent
sur place
on a des boutiques y sont encore qui
sont fermées aux clients mais qui
travaillent en click and collect donc
ils sont sur place et c'est aussi pour
eux une solution le midi parce que si
tout est fermé ils ont pas non plus de
quoi se restaurer à quelques kilomètres
de là dans cet autre restaurant à
montigny le bretonneux cette
restauratrice a perdu de nombreux
clients la vente à emporter ne séduit
pas ce jeudi midi là seulement six
clients sont venus un bon midi comparé à
d'autres c'est pas pareil comme le
premier confinement
on travaille beaucoup beaucoup moi même
il ya de gens travaillent pas du tout et
c'est très dur on a le loyer on a on a
tous le charges fixes on a on a pas mal
de choses à payer oui ça va être très
très très dur
heureusement la gérante du restaurant
peut compter sur ses clients fidèles qui
habitent à proximité de l'établissement
avec le confinement je sais que c'est
pas facile et où je me dis c'est un
moyen de soutenir les commerçants de
proximité même avec peu de clients la
restauratrice travail de 8 heures à 22
heures pour elle pas question de
fermeture
les aides de l'état devrait arriver
d'ici là pour payer notamment les
charges fixes des restaurateurs un bilan
mitigé vous l'avez vu même si certains
restaurateurs tir en ce moment leur
épingle du jeu c'est le cas de ce fou de
truck qui circulent dans les alentours
de versailles les précisions de bixente
mais rien senti steban la voix de justin
brasier pour ce reportage
le midi vous trouverez souvent aux
différents marchés de versailles
un camion citroën tout de vert vêtu à
l'intérieur deux yvelinois qui prône le
flexitarisme une alimentation que peu de
gens connaissent le flexitarisme c'est
quoi c'est simplement de manger de
manière raisonnable et raisonné donc
manger de la viande de temps en temps et
quand on en mange de qualité donc issus
d'une production responsable en tout
simplement ancien collègue devenu ami
alexander et anthony n'avait qu'une
enveloppe de 1500 euros en poche pour
lancer le projet la maison de
l'entreprise de saint quentin en
yvelines a soutenu leur démarche en leur
apportant soutien et aide financière
pour un prêt total auprès des banques de
60000 euros
anthony lui était responsable de la
partie hôtellerie mois de la partie
restauration
on a vu qu'on pouvait gérer ensemble
une entreprise et donc on s'est dit
pourquoi pas faire la nôtre
leur concept se trouve entre le fast
food et la nourriture saine avec 4
burger à la carte dont la moitié sont
végétariens alors en automne donc on
essaye de jeunes artistes locaux ont
fait un portobello donc c'est un gros
champignon c'est plus aux champignons
comestibles donc qui remplace le steak
tout simplement ça qui marche pas mal
et donc notre sel c'est
à falafel a revisité en fait confié à la
plancha le faire la poêle le soir le
camion s'installe dans différentes
villes alentour et malgré leur
confinement
la clientèle est au rendez vous le guide
terme tard s'arrête le jeudi soir sur la
place principale de saint cyr l'école et
et c'est là où on voit la première fois
je vais commander genève en jeu chez moi
et c'est dans la trouvé ça excellent
pour une première année
ouais ouais c'est carrément au delà de
nos espérances c'est un beau présage
pour l'avenir
le food trucks change de lieu selon les
jours pour savoir où le trouver il
suffit d'aller vérifier sur leur site
internet
en bref ce projet qui est finalement
abandonnée calcia renonce à son projet
d'exploitation de carrières dans le nord
des yvelines elles devaient être
réalisés sur des terres agricoles les
services de l'état avaient validé ce
projet ce qui avait provoqué une levée
de boucliers de plusieurs habitants le
géant du ciment justifie d'ailleurs sa
décision d'abandon en raison de nombreux
recours déposés conséquence la
cimenterie de gargenville sera
transformé en simple centre de broyage
dès l'année prochaine 58è des 81 93
postes du site seront donc supprimés
le déménagement du siège social de
calcia des yvelines hauts-de-seine
devrait lui être toujours maintenu la
cgt des yvelines mobilisés pendant
plusieurs jours dans le département le
syndicat va à la rencontre des salariés
pour informer sur la défense de l'emploi
et sur la protection sociale en cette
période de confinement qui suscite des
inquiétudes
rencontre distribution de tracts et
signature de pétitions les militants
étaient ce matin à la gare de saint
quentin en yvelines à montigny le
bretonneux à la cgt craint qu'avec la
crise sanitaire 20000 emplois soient
supprimés dans les yvelines
écoutez la secrétaire départementale c
est ce qu ont ce qu'on estime de la part
des plus des plus grands groupes
voilà airbus odexpo le nôtre non mais on
sait que derrière c'est des emplois de
prestataires que ainsi qu'ils ferment
qui amendent activités bas c'est aussi
moins de salariés pour le ménage pour la
restauration collective et cetera
et puis c'est tout les emplois de
proximité et peut y avoir d impact aussi
sur les sur les services publics autour
donc on est effectivement extrêmement
extrêmement inquiets et le taux de
chômage notamment pour les jeunes
particulièrement augmenté ces derniers
mois dans notre département
demain vendredi les militants de la cgt
des yvelines seront présents à la gare
de poissy le 2 décembre ce sera devant
les locaux de la cpam à mantes-la-jolie
insérer les personnes en situation de
handicap dans le monde du travail c'est
l'objectif du duo day dont la troisième
édition se déroulait aujourd'hui un
événement en pleine semaine européenne
pour l'emploi des personnes en situation
de handicap 16% d'entre elles étaient au
chômage encore l'année passée cette
année la ville de mantes la jolie
cet associé audio des six stagiaires ont
passé une journée au sein de la mairie
avec un employé volontaires afin de
découvrir un métier en vue d'une
potentielle réorientation
professionnelle bixente mayence insisté
ban une journée d'observation
d'apprentissage d'émotion pour la
semaine du handicap
la commune de mantes-la-jolie a
participé pour la première fois au duo
des six paires entre employés et
personnes en situation de handicap ont
été formés pour une journée découverte
parmi eux mélanie et christine crise
avec christine pour cette journée des
duos d où je vais lui montrer en fait un
petit peu notre environnement de travail
ce que je peux faire à l'accueil
que ce soit en état civil ou même au
standard ça se passe bien avec ma
marraine
voilà qui mal à l'aise avec ma petite
fille à la 76e pour cette journée et
j'espère que voilà que ça va faire
naître une vocation chez elle et que et
qui sait peut-être que ça va devenir une
collègue dans le futur une
sensibilisation professionnels sur la
base du volontariat que la mairie de
mantes-la-jolie a tenu à coeur de
maintenir l'objectif aussi c'est aider
ces personnes là à sortir un peu de
l'isolément de ne pas rester seul c'est
pour ça qu'il ya quelqu'un à côté et que
il accompagne le handicap c'est pas
uniquement être quelqu'un de dépendance
est aussi quelqu'un qui peut travailler
normalement avec des petites adaptations
de son environnement de travail
dany gréco sourds et muets travaille
depuis vingt ans à la mairie
son handicap n'est pas pénalisant pour
son travail un système d'interprète en
ligne a même été mise en place pour
l'aider après c'est vrai que c'est très
différent par rapport au début les
méthodes ont beaucoup changé ont évolué
on est beaucoup plus sur l'informatique
actuellement il ya des logiciels peut
passer par les cris aussi parfois pour
ce pour s'exprimer par le mime donc
enfin comme moi j'ai vraiment l'habitude
voilà j'ai cette expérience de
communiquer comme ça sans soucis depuis
toujours un duo d pour initier des
potentiels futurs employés mais aussi
pour sensibiliser chacun ou fait que
travail handicap ne sont pas
incompatibles
ce témoignage à présent celui d'aurélie
elle est yvelinoise est enceinte de
quatre mois vivent une vivre une
grossesse pendant la crise sanitaire et
le confinement n'est pas simple
difficulté de pouvoir pour avoir des
rendez vous médicaux échographie sans
son conjoint elle raconte son quotidien
au micro d'astrid bergère
[Musique]
je suis même pas malade j'ai pas de
souci particulier juste un peu de
fatigue quoi mais sinon en règle
générale ça va c'est juste les à côtés
quoi qui sont fut difficile parce que mr
en confinement ça c'est plus simple plus
difficiles comme je suis pas immunisés
contre la toxoplasmose et donc je dois
faire tous les mois c'est ses prises de
sang et les tests urinaires et ne serait
ce que pour prendre un rendez vous sur
montigny
tout ça c'est assez difficile des fois
je passe un sacré moment au téléphone
essayer de décrocher enfin ne serait-ce
qu il décroche
mais ça va j'ai la dernière fois j'ai
trouvé une du côté de la gare de
montigny samedi matin aux premières
heures j'étais très contente donc
annoncé mais c'est vraiment pas facile
colleu parce que bas ce qui est normal
les gens se ruent sur les laboratoires
pour les tests tout ça donc bah c'est un
peu embouteillée quoi
[Musique]
mon compagnon ne peut pas venir peut pas
venir avec moi parce que ben a dû à la
pandémie
en fait que la maman qui était autorisé
donc c'est un peu plus difficile parce
que bas comme monsieur pas pu venir bas
pour l'échographie on a su le sexe de
l'enfant
c'est pas simple même si monsieur peut
pas être tout le temps avec moi aux
échographies ou quoi que ce soit il
participe aussi parce qu'on a une
application en fait sur le téléphone ou
dès qu'on a fini le rendez-vous en fait
que les toutes les photos elles sont
disponibles sur l'appli donc monsieur
peut voir à tout moment que tout cela
soit un lointain souvenir qu'on puisse
profiter du bébé tranquillement avec
toute la famille
non franchement mais jouer moi perso non
je suis quelqu'un d'optimiste alors donc
moi pour moi il va y avoir que du bon de
toute façon il y aura que du bon mois le
bébé va arriver donc déjà c'est quelque
chose de magnifique et puis voilà
[Musique]
avant de refermer ce journal c'est une
élection suivi avec attention chaque
année miss france 2000 21 sera désignée
le 19 décembre puy du fou en attendant
les 29 prétendantes à la couronne vont
se préparer dans les yvelines
et dès la fin novembre en raison de la
crise sanitaire pas de voyages lointains
dans un lieu paradisiaque cette année
mais plutôt un voyage hors du temps dans
la cité royale de versailles
à quelques encablures du château les
candidates seront logés dans le cadre
luxueux du trianon palace qui sera
privatisé pour l'occasion elles rêvent
toutes de succéder à clémence bottineau
miss france 2020 voilà c'est la fin de
ce journal merci de votre fidélité vous
retrouverez demain vendredi eléonore
sinoquet pour une nouvelle édition et
dans un instant ne manquait pas un
nouveau numéro de si on rentrait
l'émission qui vous occupe pendant cette
période de confinement belle soirée avec
tv 78
[Musique]